in a three-to-one hello everybody
welcome to another episode about genius
of brains plural because we have three
genius brains today I am your host
Georgia - Kawa and I am your host David
so with his lovely partner Muriel
some you know what we found out through
23andme what say eighty percent of
Japanese acequia right here 8% 8% oh yes
now I lost my Korean I used to be 1%
Korean lost yeah when I first checked my
23 meet I was 98% Japanese 1% Korean and
I was like yeah David brother right
recently it turned into 99% Japanese I
was like oh your people came into our
stuff did you know that some stuff
there's you know ancient Korean uh-huh
is a part of Japanese blood - ancient
Korean oh okay so like there's like
different eras of ancient Japanese right
there was the Jomon era yeah and then
there was the Yayoi people's so each era
so it's almost as if like if we look at
it in America right we had the Native
American era and then we had the
Europeans that came yeah that's this
that's the second wave right Japan had
its own history like that there were
Japanese natives there were I knew and
indirect Jomon people stuff like that
and then Koreans came from Korea to
Japan and in the light-skinned Japanese
people were actually the Korean people
oh and then later on there was some you
know the Three Kingdoms like the Silla
yeah Gouri or whatever and all those
guys right one of the kingdoms I forgot
which one it was but one of the when
Korea was all split up one of the
kingdoms took over the other one yeah
and when the other one like the royalty
escaped and ran away
they married into the Japanese royal
family yeah and it's or it's recorded
history so in the royal family there's a
group of mine yeah so it's been it's
been there for a long time yeah yeah
maybe you could be a part of that
royalty maybe it's funny cuz I majored I
graduate with East Asian languages and
literature's and it was emphasized in
Japanese and I have no idea what you're
talking about I never learned that stuff
no we learned a lot of I mean I read a
lot of literature's I hate literature's
but I want I don't know why I graduated
with a degree when something I hate but
that's it I yeah like you did you ever
learn Asian history yeah we learn
ancient history I had to learn the
old-fashioned Japanese grammars do you
understand all the literature's could be
said we had to read it not only English
but also in Japanese so like there's all
these formula where we don't use it now
but then back in the day is like how
they were written it was a different
grammar structure so we had to learn we
had this like almost like a chemistry
did you read that knee home I forgot the
name of it but it's basically it's like
the history book of Japan but it tells
you like all the folklore of like
Amaterasu like dipping their arrow in
and creating it's called like the new
home I'm gonna butcher it but like
soul/psyche or some [ __ ] like that
oh so sticky it's like an ancient book
that's kind of historical and manuscript
I'm not a historical and folklore yeah
mmm we didn't have like a history book
per se Oh a lot of poetry's that's what
that nautical collection is all based
off of it's like all those like old
yeah Japanese like folklore stuff yeah
cool that's actually why I I started
liking that because I like I like
folklore in whatever country it is like
whether it's like Greek mythology issue
as some ancient alien stuff yeah so when
I would when I was watching not at all
like oh this is like that oh gee
Japanese folklore stuff mm-hmm but I
don't think a lot of people know that so
they think oh man these writers how do
they make up all these words
no knowledge II you know like yeah
I love Greek mythology dude Greek
mythology was one of those things
because I loved watching [ __ ]
Hercules with Kevin Sorbo and Xena
Warrior Princess me too yeah it was a
certain point where the chakram had the
the middle thing it was splitted - yeah
that's crazy
she was so lesbian she was hella lesbian
and that she wanted to be her lesbian no
Xena I don't know she was a lesbian she
was just really cool I didn't really
realize it till later you know I was
like wait but didn't her and Hercules
have like a thing I remember I she was a
there's one scene that I remember in
Xena specifically basically Gabriela
that passed away she died and I think
from what I remember anymore so Lucy
Lawless or Xena found like the Fountain
of Life were found in the life and then
she took the Fountain of Life water in
her mouth and then put it in Gabriella's
mouth through kissing hmm and I was like
that was so unnecessary
but my little baby boner feels so right
I'm good I got the water and but she put
it in her mouth and then she put it in
her mouth through her mouth and it was
the hottest thing I've ever seen in my
life how do you remember this is like
ever seen anything so hot that's all I
remember I don't remember too much of
that shell but I do remember two girls
kissing and sharing water in their
mouths oh you know what this is
interesting both of you guys studied
Japanese yes but she actually is good
okay attracted you to it well cuz I have
always wondered like how non-japanese
people get attracted to the culture only
because I was born in it so it's not
unique to me to me it was just all the
cartoons i watched going oh it was all
the anime and then on top of that
spanish was so distant from like korean
and japanese was so similar to it so
yeah i just assumed that a half acid and
they do well which wasn't easy eh yeah
it was easy see don't you even know that
cuz I have a I mean everyone usually
people go through anime or some kind of
cultural reasons but then I remember
specifically when I was in Middle School
I was on my computer and my grandma was
behind me watching a TV and she was
flipping the channels and we had like a
few Korean channels on like regular TV
channel or not cables and then she was
flipping and she stopped at one point
and I hear this beautiful female voice
with a language that I do not know she
hates our language no but she but she
definitely like for example right not to
put on a blast but when we talk about
having a kid right she doesn't ever talk
about teaching this kid Korean Japanese
because of there's a little girl on
Instagram have you seen this girl Oh
what's her Instagram it's like H a
something and she she's in front she's
like a two-year-old girl and she's in
front of this toilet room where her
brother is taking a dump
yeah we can't see the brother she's just
sitting there she goes and then he's
like girls like it is like a childish
language it's the way we communicate
it's like there it's a lot of baby talk
even with adults you know one thing I
realize is that Korean and Chinese and
Japanese they all we say things twice
like you would say what is it like in
Chinese you say QQ which means like
chewy but you'd replicate that or like
like dog you told you yeah in Korean
Abbey Georgia Toby in Japanese like all
those onomatopoeia would be like what's
put you or if it's really you know like
we and then they all sound kinda like
baby
it is it is QQ we don't have a lot of
automata peers yeah it's like we name
things based off based on how we think
it sounds yeah but we it sound it looks
like it sounds like that although we
understand it yeah when I was really fat
my mom would say we keep books books you
know oh yeah
which-which or like it's like there's so
many similarities dude like spit see my
itch which yeah library in Korean and
Japanese is essentially this
damn word oh yeah what I say in Korean
possible no that was one parcel Kwon is
social come in Chinese is to shoot wine
yeah I mean denwa
de moi and tell her tone wah
so it's is it the mother language has to
be Chinese then right it weren't
derivative from the characters yeah I
think so
well I think Cantonese - yeah there's a
lot of Cantonese that's similar good cuz
you guys cuz we because as kids - when
we're born are my dad knows how to write
my name in Korean and also in HoN wood
so Chinese Chinese characters yeah so I
have a Chinese character name and so
does she actually you don't have a
honeymoon my cranium is not a and that
is like officially Korean word with no
characters oh really no meaning well did
it
that's a Korean king invent the the
circle Korean style right circle circle
like yes after they learn Chinese
writing yeah it's not that long maybe
over a hundred years old very recent
yeah yeah that's so crazy
it's so convenient because Chinese
characters are so hard to remember and
yeah but you could you could read and
write though which is so weird
it's pretty legit with it when I was in
Taiwan because we had to learn what did
you learn first well when I was growing
up I spoke Korean in the house and then
we moved to Korea I went to
international school so I was kind of
learning English but there was a broken
English English and then back in middle
school Japanese Japanese and then high
school I learned Spanish till college
and then I got really interested I
started learning French Italian and all
these different languages but and after
that I was Chinese so seven but I can't
speak trying on what is it how many do
you feel like you can have a
conversation with Korean Japanese and
I'm a little bit hesitant to say Chinese
because it's been a while but I mean I
was I have to say I was pretty fluent
but if it went to Taiwan you'd be able
to get around easy that's yeah I could
get around I kind of like at these
decent conversations yeah but if I need
a work yeah that's that's most people's
like fluency level though with with the
second language that they have when
they're born in America so I say you are
relatively fluent yep
so fluid doesn't mean you're at a
college level Thuan is just like you can
have a regular combo that's the thing
the term fluent people it's it defines
it has like a vague definition to it
because people are like Oh fluent then
like go in and do this it's like no I
can't just go and do it like caught
talking to you versus talking to like
grandparents is a whole different thing
it is yeah yeah that's what people don't
understand about Japanese is that you're
it's almost like the language is
different depending on who you're
talking to
yeah cuz they're like you know James why
can't why can't you speak it and I'm
like well I would but I'd be very
offensive exactly yes my Korean baby
exactly so it's like yeah you can speak
Korean but can you say that you're
fluent you know I say I'm fluent enough
you're fluent I think you're going
between fluent and proficient yeah so if
you're proficient maybe you're like good
at like expert right but then fluent as
in like if you really need to you can't
communicate
she's proficient in Korean and I she
doesn't think so because people well
number one I feel like Korean people in
Korea even her mom told me this like her
mom told me like well when you go to
Korea it's like people are gonna look at
you weird and they probably won't like
you because you're a Korean person they
can't speak Korean well yeah like it's
it's a thing in Korea they almost like
hate you for it and I her mom told me
that IRA knew about this but I thought
maybe I'm just being a little weird
about it but her mom like she does know
like they're probably gonna cuz they're
thinking about fluency there's one thing
about learning the language and using it
correctly but you got to also understand
the culture so you know how to
communicate using that language because
for example you know in America you say
if someone tells you oh you look pretty
and you say oh thank you I'm flattered
you accept that compliment whereas in
Asia if you say that then you're like
you're you have a big ego yeah cuz you
don't accept that you do fine in
multiple times but there's a good way to
remedy this and I told her mom this she
goes well what are you gonna do in Korea
when they know you're Korean you can't
speak Korean well I'm like come come on
Chinese and they're gonna be impressed
I'm a Chinese I speak accordion you know
that's what my grandma told me
you come to Japan don't speak Japanese I
mean I'll do it now I don't give a [ __ ]
you know cuz like there's so many non
Japanese in Tokyo yeah that they are
used to foreigners or Asian Americans or
Asian Australians practicing Japanese
they're cool with that they're very
accommodating yeah but when I go into
the countryside or whatever you know
they usually ask for my story they'll be
like oh wait so so you must be like a we
call it neat gay yeah which is like a
Japanese born out of the country yeah
yeah so so don't be like oh you you're a
neat gay huh and I'm like yeah I am
they're like what part you were born
there how many generations and they'll
ask me and they're usually interested
yeah and you're like yeah that's dope
man
that's dope that you even speak it
that's that's interesting cause like in
Korean it's it's different like like
kill Paul yeah right like that it's it's
almost like a negative thing to have
people really used to used to be before
they became like before Korea got really
popular it used to be a like a down
thing where people were like oh you just
like ran away from our country you just
left our country kind of feeling like
you don't even care about our culture
and you come and try to like you know
yeah cool cuz you're from America they
had a stigma it's not like that anymore
um no it's a little bit different me
like many people it's weird because it
almost feels like so like I have a
friend who's who told me about this and
this is how he felt he goes you feel
like you don't you're somebody without a
man without a land like you don't belong
in America Americans look at you funny
because you don't have like this perfect
English accent yeah but you kind of
identify yourself as an American but
you're like well [ __ ] it well if I'm not
going to hear that if I go back to Korea
I should be accepted but they're like no
you ran away to America so you're
[ __ ] trash over there too so you just
feel like lonely you feel alone no but
nobody accepts you that's how I felt
when I was there cuz when I was there
when I around third grade we moved to
Korea and back then I didn't really I
didn't speak English or Korean it was
just like kind of like whatever we
spoken in the house so when I went there
I see I realized oh there's so many
Koreans like people who look like me
yeah
but then those Koreans were like you're
not one of us yeah there were me I was
in that Mean Girls world yeah
man those girls could be like she talks
about this to me till this day like it
happened yesterday
it was culture there's a lot of bullying
in Japanese and Korean culture yes
amazing there's a lot of are you good
enough to be one of us kind of like I
think that's where we're very similar
yeah cuz even my mom talks about it
right yeah I told my mom about the
situation that she had em I was like
yeah that happened all the time when I
was a little kid like that yeah the
pretty girl in the school yeah you
should get beat up and punk all the time
because she was too pretty pretty and
made took the attention away from the
other girls yeah we were talking about
this and this came in conversation with
my mom because I mentioned this and I
also mentioned this Korean movie that I
saw were these girls like took a razor
and cut this girl's face cuz she was
super cool and then my mom's I yeah that
can happen yeah my mom like I did bash
the tomboy doses to hang out with like a
lot of boys and you know she's like
she's really rough around the edges
that's how it was I hung out with the
boys
yeah the girls hated that yeah yeah and
so I was always like the outsider I
remember one time the girls it was like
maybe ten students in one classroom
there were five guys and five girls and
the girls four of them will like become
a team and they wore the same clothes or
like they would match and I'll be the
left I'll be the outsider and I was
hanging out with the dudes cuz there's
so much more fun yeah you would hate
that so they charged me I just want to
have fun yeah yeah and I want it the
same thing guys have drama over the
stupidest [ __ ] like I could throw longer
the far further than you yeah I didn't
they fight over like who could throw the
furthest or something when you're in
elementary or something right I I can
remember the very first fight that I've
ever had in kindergarten and it was it's
the stupidest thing I was playing house
in kindergarten you know where they had
the play area and we're playing house
and I wanted to cook some soup and this
person try to take my Oh like a play
house yeah you're playing house and then
I'm cooking soup this person took the
pie out of my head I grabbed the pot
head away little face with it that was
like the second day of kindergarten oh
my gosh yeah boys fight over stupid [ __ ]
Thomas there I wanted to cook soup and
he wouldnt let me cook soup so in his
face Oh we'll have it to the kid cried
he was crying his [ __ ] pie
yeah why would you slap his head because
he took my stupid pot you went food I
swear girls too though because there
were I think the only girls that did
really play with us were Tom boys yeah
they would come with us and then like we
would hop fences and play in people's
backyards and there's there there was
there's always these girls in elementary
school that were so boyish they were
scary because he would beat up the boys
yeah do you remember who your girl was
in elementary school I remember mine her
name was there was two girls there was
one named jewel and there was another
girl named Zakia so jewel was [ __ ]
crazy you know you know like when you
see like a cartoon like a country
bumpkin with like a short red that's
what she looked like but picture that
but she had braids and knockers in her
hair yeah this [ __ ] would knock dudes
out dude
she would play Phi so hard like I
couldn't shoot made the guys cry yeah
and I couldn't I should hit me so hard I
couldn't feel my [ __ ] arm it was one
of those girls who have punched guys
arms and pull guys here and make them
cry what'd he mean was right here how
long did you live in Korea for I think
less than three years over two years and
then we came back because I couldn't
handle it oh it was for you yeah most
for me and my pet we had a lot of family
coming third great ten years old no was
it remember that I remember it because
it was a culture shock but also that's
where like I built a foundation of like
who I was I guess because prior to that
we moved around so much that I didn't
really have like much memory of it yeah
and in Korea it's like we're sticking up
for two and a half years and so I met
some really good people good friends but
it was a culture shock and back then
Korea was still developing so it was
super ghetto everything was cheap there
was like barely subways were being
invented people don't realize how fast
Korea turned their economy around it's a
new country they don't realize that it
just started in nineteen fifty something
like if there's anything ever to be
proud about being Korean it's like how
resilient we are yeah I think cultural
wise when I look back at it and I see
from an outside perspective and we
realize like 1950s and we're how much of
a powerhouse of of like
cultural influence Korea has now in a
span of like 60 years from from a
desolate country they got ravaged by war
it's a very small population yeah
compared to very concentrated yeah it's
like half the population of Vietnam or
something it's [ __ ] yeah it's like a
quarter of Japan or something like very
small population but like they'd the
turnarounds insane before Korea the
success story was Japan right like
war-torn country and then it took them I
don't know like a couple decades to
become an industrialized nation yeah but
then I think Korea's faster than that
yeah 20 years we are doing it's like a
repeat of Japan history though because
what Japan and now Korea is doing it and
Korea is now like a situation where it's
like okay we're at the peak now is just
like what do we do now and then now it's
China who's doing that yeah and it's
just gonna be yen is gonna go to
Southeast Asia it's like it's everyone
goes through this industrial like
revolution and whatever her if it's like
happening in Vietnam right now
yeah its Southeast Asia it's so crazy
like all these factories and businesses
are opening up there and it's like
become you know we're the last frontiers
gonna be Africa oh yeah dad even think
about that huh now China is middle class
is like they have like 300 million
people in a minute sorry that is the
same so imagine that's America that's
how many be what we have here imagine if
everyone in America was middle class
that's crazy that's China so so they're
doing better than us in terms of helping
out I don't know because ratio is right
yeah because if they have a billion yeah
and only 300 million that that means
here it's it that means it's growing so
it's gonna go past that yeah but a lot
of their manufacturing now is going to
Africa so China's outsourcing that's the
craziest thing I've ever heard of my
life
that's why Southeast Asia is making
money because China is outsourcing to
them now that's insane yeah holy [ __ ]
dude I know weird when you move to UM
when you move to America and you came
here right you told me that you had
problems with because so we go back to
this if we go back to her when she was
in Korea there's this photo that she
showed it me like three
during Halloween Oh okay let me tell let
me tell you I'm sorry so this is crazy
okay so I was Korea in Korea 197 ish and
then come over here and it's Alan 2019
and I'm scrolling through Instagram on
my newsfeed and no joke like I don't
talk to any of the people or any of the
classmates that I was with at my school
in Korea I mean I wasn't really friends
with them but I'm scrolling through this
newsfeed and no joke I see a familiar
faces or familiar faces and I was like
oh what the hell is this this is like me
what is this doing here and I click it
and it's a picture of my classmates and
I in how during Halloween oh [ __ ] I
don't even remember this day yeah
and it's a picture of our classmate or
it is a pic photo of my teacher the guys
and then the girls me yeah I'm like what
the hell is this when was it sounds like
oh my god this was me in third grade at
Seoul International School and I
remember that costume that I made
because it was really sad my parents are
so sad my mom's very against Halloween
because of culture yeah Christian yeah
yeah but the school site hey bring
something to wear because we're gonna
celebrate it
yeah and so I got a piece of a a white
t-shirt yeah the only thing I I was able
to do was get my marker my black marker
draw circles everywhere and what were
your ghosts get a string dalmatian Oh
put it on my blood ghetto Dalmatian dog
if you see the photo though what's even
more sad is that the guys all have their
own poster right yeah the girls are in
the center I'm on the side yeah the
girls are in the center I did not
realize this they all wore fairy costume
together to get her out so you're just a
dog on a side yeah
damn not even a dog it's like that dog
in the is one of those dogs is all
raggedy of the
oh my god those girls specifically
decided to leave her out of the girl
clique group yeah and so she had to show
up in this ghetto little halloween car
and that's the stuff that like mentally
messed her up so that was your friends
or what that one of the girls Instagram
where the boys are oh yes I was like
where is this photo coming from yeah and
it's from the girl who made my life
miserable she was what is that girl
named Gretchen no not Gretchen Gretchen
what a miserable man no from Mean Girls
I don't know I forgot yeah but she was
that one girl yeah who led everyone else
to hate me yeah she was like the leader
cuz the other girls they were friends
with me and like we were there like I
can't do it anymore because of this girl
the both hate me so they got they got
bullied into it I guess yeah she was
like the king she pretended to be your
friend and everything she did I get for
she was like my good friend and then
these new girls come in and I'm like
friends with them and that later on she
finds out I don't know I guess she got
jealous of like how close I got with all
these friends oh these girls yeah and so
she decided that hey let's leave her out
and somehow she then persuaded that hey
that girl don't play with her
yeah sure enough that happened and I was
like what the Freak you must be so sad I
was sad and you know what yeah I think
that was like a milestone for me to have
interest in other languages though
because you're like [ __ ] this group I
hate this culture yeah but you can't
blame all the Koreans be a child crazy
like revelation to have in third but I
had a really young age right isn't it
crazy how I got picked on pretty hard
but I never I don't know like it's crazy
that I found it on Instagram how did you
know concern did you stalk her you let
you [ __ ] dick you [ __ ] tongue
cannot be a [ __ ] sometimes I like to
see my old bullies and in and be like
God your life sucks so bad it's like
good for you god is great
God
about the Karma funny thing is is that
later on I did have a best friend at
that school I went back in middle school
to go visit her and she was telling me
that that girl actually failed fourth
grade and had to video that way bullies
are just really [ __ ] up oh yeah she
probably I was mentioning that to her I
was like you know if that was the case
there was probably something that was
going on in her household that probably
made her ya wanna feel like super
important and special during school and
it's so funny because we got into this
conversation in the car after that and
she sometimes she gets stuck on words
yeah and I think it causes a lot of
friction between us because I said like
oh well how come you're not over at that
Scheels I'm over it and I'm like well
definitively you're not over it because
you're talking about as if it happened
yesterday like you're angry yeah about
she goes but that it could mean I'm over
it and I'm like yeah you're not over it
I'm just telling it's still affecting
you when you talk about it uh I think so
but it's not like I have anything
against her you have a resentment but
then when you relive it you feel the
sadness again it's very good so so in
that sense you're not over it that way
yeah yeah over the anger you're over the
whole like I don't wish anything bad for
her but I put it to her like this too
because she was I told her I was like
well if you saw her today like college
you react she goes killer I'll pray for
her you can't you can't deny it the
Koreans in U K rage but it's so crazy
cause like if I look back in my past and
I see everybody who did something wrong
to me yeah I don't get angry
either I'm just like man whatever you
know I think I would feel sad at those
people who were [ __ ] turn out to be
billionaires yeah that may be sad well I
mean haven't we all we all made mistakes
is what I like to think and then also I
had this recent revelation it's kind of
like hey sometimes you have to go
through pain
to realize certain things so I was
talking to my friend the other day and
you know we both had kind of deadbeat
dads he's he's a he's a multimillionaire
like he he's he's really successful and
him and his brother built like an
amazing company together and in and he's
like you know I could sit here and be
angry that my dad was a gamble holic and
we had a great life upper middle-class
life but because he gambled everything
away me and my brother had to work so
hard to pay for the family and at such a
young age I think they were just in high
school they were they had to pay for
like grown people bills yeah and then
they the family owned a doughnut shop
and then they were losing that and then
he's like but if I didn't have to go
through that he's like I wouldn't be
sitting here with you today doing
business with you yeah and then I was
like you know what you're right like if
if I didn't go through the pain with my
dad leaving there's not I wouldn't learn
so many things yeah so it's like hey
maybe you wouldn't have learned so many
languages yeah because that opened you
up to say oh [ __ ] I want to learn
different languages and different
cultures yeah yeah yeah that's kind of
weird because like I always thought I
think about if all these like negative
stuff help mold Who I am today
I wonder what's gonna help build my kids
character you got to keep mcdu negative
[ __ ] on purpose I start jumping all of
our kids I feel like you don't have to
construct negative negative things if
they'll have their own set of problems
yeah like don't get picked on at school
or something there's enough negative
stuff that's happening that we don't
don't worry about that big part of me is
kind of like I want my kid to do
jiu-jitsu kickboxing but the other half
of me is like I don't want him to learn
because one day he might kick my ass or
maybe he'll protect me at least or [ __ ]
yeah so I mean all those experiences
were I I mean there are great memories
to talk about yeah so it shows that I
have some characters I guess yeah cuz I
bet you there's someone listening right
now and they're still working out their
problems about how they got picked on
and whatever
and in there they're like still stuck
like I think for me at least I went
through like years like just hating
people that did bad to me you know just
hating them and I was like if I catch
them I'm gonna [ __ ] murder them I
hate them so much but then like after a
while it's like what can you do you
can't control the past you can't control
what they did you can't you could sit
there and think about it a lot but it
just ruins your life people hold onto
things like when I was uh when I was in
elementary school I told her story right
where I stabbed this kid in the face and
from from like eight okay yeah
so from 8 all the way till we were till
I was like what 13 I was in middle
school mm-hmm so in that like what a
four to five period time that full
carried that anger all the way till
middle school yeah and then he jumped me
in middle school so he came from that
long to come and jump me and bus stop I
mean so some people just you know for me
when I saw him I wasn't scared I was
like oh that's the kid that I said like
this is me I'm thinking about when
you're the bully you don't realize I
wasn't but he tried to bully me so he
tried to bully me you just just reacted
out of anger uh long story short the guy
pushed me out of my chair during class
so some people were throwing spitballs
yeah and they were throwing spitballs
and then he got hit in the head and I
was just doing my homework and [ __ ] he
thought you you got a I did it cause I
was dying laughing you know so he
assumed that it was me he comes up and
I'm like whatever I got done laughing I
just went back to my work out of nowhere
this kid just Chuck's me out of my chair
just are standing on me angry and I you
know I'm still writing [ __ ] and so I'm
you know holding that's just you know
kids with a punch they don't punch like
jabs bosses uppercuts I sort of hammer
fisting yeah hammer fist at his face
yeah
so that motion the stabbing motion and I
went through his chicken into his mouth
hole and so so he probably saw it as
like you hurt my feelings you're
laughing at me and then you beat me up
oh you didn't do it uh he I try to tell
a math that he just didn't believe me
like I didn't know you were lying yeah
and the weird thing was I will never I
was never the troublemaker in the school
so how why would I be the one doing the
spit ball thing maybe he just got his
feelings hurt because you're laughing
probably because I was laughing my ass
off what
I was laughing pretty hard thought I
wrote of that I so that experience
didn't stop from there though like I am
I'm such a I was such an innocent kid
innocent and a naive that it occurred so
many times to me like and after I came
back here booing yeah only being an
outsider because when I came back I was
so happy that we were back but then I
realized that it's not the same world
that I recalled yeah and then I went to
a private Christian school that had no
Asians hella bully third where was that
this was in Long Beach PQR ple be
talking about purple yeah this podcast
is brought to you by purple my friends
if you let me say something if you don't
know about purple the number one you
must be out of your mind because I love
my purple mattress not even as a joke
I'm for real Z for real Z because it
definitely solved the problem that I had
before when I had my other mattress it's
like number one for some reason all my
other mattresses they would make me hot
hot as heck my friends and I'm telling
you right now
purple somehow manages to always stay
cold there's some kind of technology in
there and I will tell you what I bet you
didn't know this that purple was
actually created by a rocket scientist
I'm talking about their science behind
this there's science to making a
mattress somehow soft yet firm at the
same time we're talking about the story
of porridge my friends is the porridge
too hot is the porridge too cold guess
what
no it's purple baby that's what's up so
check this out
hahahahahaha you are going to love
purple and right now my listeners will
get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text brain to
eight four - eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is detects
brain - eight four - eight eight eight
that's be are a I n two eight four eight
eight eight message and data rates may
apply mmm ah Beach Long Beach yeah there
was no Asians huh I went to this private
school that howling why black Mexican
including all the teachers and
saying the kids bullied me which they
did but not only the kids but the
teachers too Wow [ __ ] crazy
yeah it's like what the hell and I was
like so down that we finally moved to
another place and we settled there we're
like we're gonna stay here for a bit yes
how did the teachers pull you though for
example we were we had a uniform and I
always tuck my shirt in cuz I was one of
the rules and but then my shirts were a
little bit bigger than what it should be
yeah and they would get mad at that
they'd be like why your shirt they'll
think because I'm not a fat American
that's why they're like there they're
just like a aggressive and condescending
yeah yeah and not to mention I didn't
really speak English at that time
because I just called from Korea so I
don't understand the culture and
understand what they're saying and also
it's like this Christian language that
I'd had no idea what they were talking
about like salvations revolutions like
what the hell do too many syllables
that's a big-ass [ __ ] horse so I was
so confused and then finally they
decided to move again and that's where I
stayed in Diamond Bar and they're like
you're we're gonna stay here I'm like
tons of Asians tons of Asian I was so
happy I found my Koreans yeah I was like
yes I could talk to them one girl came
up to me she's like we're gonna be best
friends I'm like yay she prints all
these certificates and really cute stuff
saying like you and I was best friends
for the best friends what the hell this
is awesome like I feel so welcome yeah
long story short [ __ ] man Wow
and I cuz I like at first I was like I I
was kind of scares was like you're are
you gonna hurt me too and then she gave
me all these certificates like oh he
must be really knows legit did yeah at
the end of my 6th grade yeah my whole
class yeah did not like me why because
this girl yeah started a rumor yeah that
I was talking crap about everyone and
but the she how long were you best
friends with therefore so what's that
[ __ ] do it now so because I'm the new
girl in town and everybody knew each
other from elementary yeah she knew
everyone and she thought I don't know
what what made her think like oh this
gonna be fun because everybody was being
nice to me he's like oh the new girl
she's nice
so like let's say hi to her so I was
like making friends and next thing I
know like everyone's giving you this
weird look I didn't want to talk to you
anymore I think you know like oh don't
talk to that girl yeah I was like hey
what's going on like why are they like
give me my look and she's like oh honey
like they don't like you annoying well
that's so mean yeah girls are [ __ ]
[ __ ] girls are so much you know what I
thought was weird is that
um so most I think in most groups women
bring the guys together mmm
in our group we brought all the women
together oh that's right it's the other
way around
oh yeah well you have your own set of
girl Frank about like the JK group right
yeah yeah because they said that I mean
from G Oh Jess everybody they said it
was really hard for them to get close to
girls and in there like I was like why
don't you just like find a hobby
together and start like bonding off of
that she's like it doesn't work like
that for girls yeah cuz guys are like
that don't you like fishing I like
fishing and then while you're fishing
you talk about life there's a lot of
elements that get involved and let's
chill them together like guys I think
we're simple creatures yeah I mean not
to say that there aren't there's no
drama and it happens there's
insecurities there's there's all that
stuff that happens but it's easier to
feel closer and have friends yeah yeah I
didn't you know in elementary school
when I would girls would do that whole
manipulative thing right they play this
game for a guy that's too much work just
punch him in the face do you like you're
a little [ __ ] yeah they Duke it out so
conniving but I feel like in your
situation these girls are so conniving
and manipulative they're already
developing a plan being friends with you
for a whole [ __ ] semester just to
crush you at the yeah it doesn't make
sense
that's so you yeah and so but that being
said God loves me you know what goes
around comes around she died no okay but
she used her sister and uh her older
sister's name for some reason and sent
me this email my mom Maxentius
accidentally saw it
and it was just like cursing me out you
you [ __ ] you better know I'm like make
fun of my sister or like you know yeah
make moment my sister whatever she was
just like Chrissy it was a threatening
letter yeah basically and I was like
what the hell is this and then my mom
was just mad about it but this was
towards the end of 6th grade somehow the
whole school kind of found out about
what she has done and that it was a lie
yeah and I was and I was I was sad I was
a mad at her I was sad because I loved
the front yeah I was like I think you
remind those a fake friend the whole
time yeah so when seventh grade came
around I found out that she moved to a
different city he said I couldn't I
don't know I don't know what the reason
is but thank God she moved to a
different city he went to a different
school and that's actually when I
learned oh I need something called
attitude so people don't mess with me I
get that I learned it I was like you
know what I'm done with this but sure
enough like getting scarred do someone
people come up to you in seventh grade
like hi my name is Jessica [ __ ] you
Westside homey this is when I learned
like girls got I have a friend yeah like
you say you smile say hi but like you
better be careful because you don't know
what that person has damn
you do a pretty good job because you
actually do have a good solid set of
girlfriends now like you actually you
actually really do which I don't see a
lot of that's where my best friend
that's good cuz now you know how to weed
out the frauds you know how to weed out
you build street smarts it's so comes
normal yeah it is so after you like now
we can smile it out yeah yeah like if
it's like oh yeah this this person is
not genuine mm-hmm you could tell if
they have other motives even if
everything that they're saying is right
yeah there's a feeling yeah yeah and I
think if you don't let those things ruin
you that's why I'm kind of like I kind
of want my kid to get home to get [ __ ]
over I want them to build some streets
yeah because it's worse when you're an
adult and you have to go through yeah
people don't get that man they're like
you want your kid to get bullied it's
like I think you're getting hung up on
the word it's more like people are gonna
do this to you either way you know III
think like we see these campaigns
stop bullying I a hundred percent agree
I think there should be a little bit of
realism when people say that it's like
get people to realize that it's wrong so
when you do see it you'll step in and
you'll help these people but you can't
prevent it from happening it's it's in
animal nature like there's predators in
the real world what you're doing is
you're you're protecting your babies too
much to when they when they become
adults they don't know what to do when a
predator is there they're gonna eat you
because I think a better thing for
people to do is is to continue to you
know try to stop bullying but something
that's more important is the teacher get
how to deal with it when it happens yeah
you know how do I deal with the
situation when somebody's attacking me
for no [ __ ] reason how do I step up
step up to that challenge how do I grow
from the situation because for us we had
to figure out the hard way the hard way
is yeah we used violence or something
stupid and we are we reacted but there's
there's a more intelligent way to deal
with everything I know yeah but
sometimes punching somebody in the face
oh I'm sure it's like it's like sneezing
it feels so good right after you do it
I've never done this I don't know it's
like it's you know when you're a kid -
there's like a certain level of
vindication I think like when I was a
kid like I remember when people would
bully me and I would hit them I doing it
made me feel like you will never ever do
that [ __ ] to me oh yeah and like I had
to take a stand because what was I
supposed to do and especially like you
know we talked about this before where
we you let how we grew up if somebody
did that to you once they were gonna do
it again and again and again
they took my lunch money once they'll do
it tomorrow I'll do the day after so
when you step up and you punch them in
the face or you tell them that it's
gonna be hard for you to take my money
they're gonna go on to the next victim
yeah and it was hard because I and
principals - at that time they didn't
care they didn't care about the
narrative about who was getting hurt
first they had to deal with so much
[ __ ] on a regular basis they just
said everybody's wrong and there was no
solution so that after you go to the
principal you you think you expect
things to be solved but the next day the
kid does the same [ __ ] again because
they don't give a [ __ ] so what you do
you go after school you fight them
somebody gets beat up or if you don't
they just know that if I try to take
this kids money it's gonna be a lot more
difficult so I have to go to somebody
else that's why I learned it's like
you've got to save yourself no one's got
no one else is going to say
you in that Ellie's in that world let's
go you know what sir could I still got
my own bubble that I got I survived on
but yeah but those if I didn't go
through that lesson then I wouldn't have
known how to save myself and you know
being the real world where you're not
around my parents are not around like
you're gonna survive right yep and then
I don't know why they would they want to
shelter people cuz when they I've seen
it I've seen full-grown adults crumble
at the most simplest [ __ ] yeah it's like
because their coworker was kind of
bullying them they just cry and quit the
job I'm like you can't do that as an
adult you have to pay your bills did you
forget about the the electricity bill
and water the food you have to eat it's
like you're not a child anymore but
because you know they've been protected
all their lives yes the first time
they're dealing with something like that
and I feel sad for them like whoa I'm
kind of glad that I'm I went through
what I did you know if we worked at a
regular like workspace like I kind of
wonder how I would deal with it because
it's it's pretty toxic man yeah the
corporate world is so toxic that's why I
build my own businesses because one of
the reasons why is is freedom I would
much rather work 24 hours a day than to
work eight hours a day with people that
I hate yeah yeah it's it's very
political too because you can't say
there's things that you would say
outside of this work setting but
obviously within the work sitting
there's a work culture and there's also
your ass on the line so you can't come
up to somebody who's let's say they're
very passive aggressive they say some
[ __ ] like oh it's like what a good what
a good coffee choice it would suit
someone like you like so uh you know
when somebody said that right and you
look in that like in reality outside of
this workspace you would stop him say
what the [ __ ] did you just say to me
well you know that's why I can't do why
I call it work yeah that's I
specifically when I did work I tried
doing the office thing but I always went
back to blue collared work always to the
because it's more of a real environment
yeah we talk [ __ ] whatever and in I like
physical work but even though I have the
mental capabilities of working in the
office and doing that stuff I hate the
culture and I hate the people that's
what Holly
feels like some yams you know and she
knows it too because when I have to go
through these like type of mixers she
just hears me like complain about this
[ __ ] cuz it's so annoying you know
because I feel like I have to put that
white like you put it what the white
color works you know
hey how's it going said oh you know that
project I love that dude how did you do
that it was so inspired and I would sit
there and I have to hear this [ __ ] all
the time and for me like it's like a
script it's a script yeah I could play
that damn game but it's all in my face
yeah people can tell when I don't like
somebody so it's like you sound happy
but your face looks angry dude I'm like
okay maybe I shouldn't go to these
things then because it's hard for me to
do that not have an [ __ ] it's just I
don't have to deal with that on my
regular basis so I don't have to play
that political game you know
specifically like in JK like we we have
chemistry we understand and it's really
open and communication it's already an
understanding I'm on what's going on I
think I'm just used to meeting new
people just because that's how I grew up
you know looking in different places
that
yeah there's those stuff where you know
it sucks that you work for a company and
there's all these politics and you have
to go with the flow because that's just
how it works or else you really fire but
for me I see the other side is like I
get to meet new people I get to hear
their stories you know there are people
who I won't like but there are people
more people who I like I do like yeah
you're right now cuz not everyone in the
company sucks there's some people that
are genuinely cool and you build some
good friendships yeah yeah but that's
why people like that show the office so
much because it's like so true it's true
like people see it and they're like yo
that's an exaggeration of life and to a
certain extent it is but people know
people like Dwight couple know people
like Jim and uh Angela - god these
people are actual office people that you
deal with like even working in a in a
work setting like I was kind of like the
prankster - even when I worked a
part-time job at the Men's Wearhouse I
would they send out an email at the
Men's Wearhouse because there was an
employee that was prank calling
everybody all over all over every member
of you and that was me because because
you know we would do so many accents
yeah and I would practice my actions by
doing that [ __ ] at them at Matt's
employees and because I can look up
every single wedding tux inventory stuff
and see who's booking [ __ ] yeah I
can make up stories and I could try to
get them to change these orders so for
example you entertained yourself
I was bored so when it wasn't tuck
season so that's a prom and a wedding
season I would sit in that store for
like ten hours and nobody would come in
oh yeah so I got really bored I was
bored out of my [ __ ] mind so I
remember one of the funniest ones that I
did or to me anyways there was this dude
that you still work across from us I'm
talking about there was a Men's
Wearhouse tuxedo and literally a
30-second walk there was a major Men's
Warehouse and I practiced by prank
calling this one dude named anis
so there's any ado and so there was a
there was a wedding order for a huge
Vietnamese wedding and so I just did the
Vietnamese accent
this dude was getting [ __ ] frustrated
because I was like hello can I tell you
that I want to change my tuxedo to do
the red white and blue because I'm going
to get my citizenship we don't have a
white we can't do that it was like but I
love America so I need to have a blue
tie the red bed and the white tuxedo
please getting frustrated he goes which
orders this and I know the exact order
number order number 1750 that's the one
with it has Trin and 1 in it I also want
them to have purple because he's gay so
for them they kind of feel like it's a
prank call but because I know everything
they'll [ __ ] this is actually a real guy
yeah but it it kind of got around
because I too many that's dough yeah but
that's you know and at that time I'll
start beast at a comic too so it was
good for me is like exercise you know
practice these accents you doing like it
was good that job but you were doing
really want that job I didn't really
love the job though cuz you know on the
times when I was working I work [ __ ]
hard man like I'm talking about like I
did really well in retail and when I
quit they were actually offering me an
assistant manager position but I was
like it doesn't make any [ __ ] money
and it's dobbs exhausting why would I
tell I'd rather work this regular job
make a little less but a more freedom
that's how I feel about most jobs and
workplaces it's for
I think the world is a half a sir yeah
like I I you know like I like to [ __ ]
go hard and I care about the company cuz
and I always look at it like hey if this
was my business you know what would I do
yeah and then like I get mad at my team
members I get mad at like the the the
stupidity and then like for me it's like
why don't people work hard yeah I feel
like that's the Asian side is it because
I had other non Asian friends that were
like like you know that had the same
mentality at the job and like and then I
would team up with them and then like
there's people that would get mad
because it's like if you work too hard
then it makes them look bad and they
don't want you to work too hard or like
some people only care about politics
yeah they suck yeah because they
kiss-ass really well yeah they know how
to get I'm not the latter exactly so
it's like it doesn't matter if you're
effective but I don't know I cared about
results a lot yeah and I think like
partially to for us like my my manager
at that Men's Wearhouse I still talk to
him to this day like we're still really
close and the good thing the great thing
about him was he wasn't like I don't
think he graduated college right but in
terms of his work output he was the best
like our little store kicked everybody's
ass and it was specific specifically
because he was that amazing and even
taught us how to be efficient in how to
measure people and get them ready for
tuxedos yeah so we would come in if
there was a group of like six or seven
we could knock everybody out in two
minutes then come in what do it like
this and then it got to a point where
some people when they measure people
they're unsure about stuff but because
I've saw it so much and repent he
trained is so often we rarely ever had
to do reorders yeah cuz that's how fast
and efficient we were we can knock
people [ __ ] out and mind you for him
too as a manager what I really liked
about him was that number one he wasn't
making a [ __ ] ton of money either so he
couldn't give us monetary incentives but
even just him showing appreciation to us
and letting us know that we're doing a
great job made me want to work hard yeah
so a lot of the times when when I feel
like young people want jobs now they go
well this is just a part-time job I'm
gonna part-time work here so I'm a half
but that's such a bad habit to have
because that trash if you think that you
could have this attitude here at a
part-time job you're gonna have it at
your full-time job
period end of story so you should be
able to work this job like you give a
[ __ ] about even though you know this is
not where you're going to end up it's
great habits I take it back it's not the
Asians because I was just as you were
talking I was older I was thinking about
my my previous job my team our
production team where it was I was the
only Asian but we have three people in
our production team for a project call
of death and robots I was released
recently on Netflix dope though bro yeah
that's Netflix you'll [ __ ] about it
though we had we had a big project to
work on there was only three of us we
were a small but mighty team and I have
to say like no one has I've never seen
anyone work that hard for a company like
they we were on earth we were there so
many hours and working so hard but at
the same time we were making sure that
we were supporting each other that's
dope
and it was probably the hardest job I've
ever done in my life and I had a lot of
jobs but at the same time I was very
rewarding because of the people you know
yep they're not looking about like oh I
gotta do best so I could get promoted
it's like we're doing this together
we're putting two hundred percent effort
in here because we care yeah it's not
our company but we care yep
so and that's that's how I always like
to work except for school projects [ __ ]
that schools different yes I guess but
then I think in the workplace I'm
thinking you know we got to make the
company better yeah we got to give it
better results because when they see
that this department is making things
like more efficient making more money
they might give us a better chance you
know what's interesting
remember you were talking about how
boarding oh really
you know how Ford made constructor the
eight hour work week yeah but now it's
easy even coming to the point because of
Technology and because of how efficient
things are even the eight hour work week
is done yeah you know it actually
creates
more and work more burnout yeah it's a
way so like if you look at office and
Club and I have a friends who a lot of
friends who work for the state I know
for a fact they get their job done and
they can get it done in the first four
or five hours right yeah but a lot of
state jobs is a lot of work manipulation
because it's like this right let's say
like they have an initiative to solve
this education problem they put you on
now you could solve the problem in four
years yeah but you want your job till
you retire yeah cuz after the problem
solved what are you gonna do you don't
have any work hmm
so they want to keep their job so they
have to write this happens a lot
like whether it's state jobs even in the
movie industry like there's people that
are like like this is what Steve told me
like there's there's guys that are there
they're hired to look over the script
and and supervised right yeah sometimes
a script is perfect they like it but
they have to justify their job so now
they make revisions even though they
don't want you to but they just do it
and scribble some [ __ ] to prove that day
they got to justify their position
that's why these do that remember like
in production because we would shoot
these sketches and then sometimes these
production companies come up to us
they're like well you know we was a
bunch of like 15,000 I'm like it's
[ __ ] $100 bro yeah walking about and
that's how derive your [ __ ] is yeah like
you have a small it's like it's small
set like okay let me give you an example
YouTube bread during this time they were
shelling out a lot of money to do all
these like small projects yeah small
projects that were gonna become
something bigger so I hopped on one
where they asked me to feature on the
set now mind you this this script I
can't remember the exact I think we were
shooting and I might be even
exaggerating this it might have only
been one page but I think we're shooting
two pages that day they had me on set
and it took them I [ __ ] [ __ ] you not
like at least seven or eight hours to
shoot two pages why cuz a crew of like
20 people or something like wow like a
ridiculous amount of people and i sat
there like what the [ __ ] are you guys do
you're wasting time by the way too
in two cameras so they didn't even have
to switch it to cameras then a to camp
set up to Red's they had a whole team of
gaffers everything right to the [ __ ]
nine and they couldn't shoot like a page
or two in a matter of like an hour I
should have been yeah couple hours and
that scene was so [ __ ] simple if we
hours max yeah yeah the scene was so
simple by the way it was just them
coming in making up making a couple of
jokes I'm the bartender I say something
weird seem done and it took them that
long and they're like yo this this is
how much this is gonna cost like no no
no you are trying to justify your
paycheck right now because this right
here didn't need to take that long you
wasted everybody's time yeah it was so
[ __ ] dumb and then the director was
having was arguing with with the gaffer
and the gaffer was arting with you I
said what the [ __ ] is going on with this
set you know I was gonna break for a
second it's like oh my god dude it's a
simple bar scene it was so simple but
yeah thank you thank you for that
that's what that's what girls are
important yeah to let you know how
disgusting you are but that's how much
people waste yeah yeah but that's that's
what happens a lot in the corporate
space in the work space and that's what
becomes people's reality in their
standard but I I love running businesses
and working with people I care about
because everything we do is effective
work yeah everything matters right like
and it's result based so it's like we
could put a ton of hours into something
but sometimes if we didn't do the right
moves we get zero or we actually lose
money but I love that risk yeah are you
learn from it yeah don't ever do that
again and I care and I rather do that
than be a part of that being a part of a
group that just milks money or just
manipulates the system and then they're
like a human leech or whatever like
that's that's their style of working and
it's inefficient and it's [ __ ] stupid
and I can't deal with that because I
feel like there's no true progress and
how can you be proud of that yeah we we
even know people in production or I know
somebody in production right now where
they know somebody above then that's
that's not their job that literally just
creates work for them to do so they can
look important
their boss yeah you know like it's like
a racket dude it's like a it's it's so
[ __ ] up but I get it everybody needs
to survive yeah but that's why I like to
work in a company that cares about
people because if you're only caring for
yourself and it's it's gonna shatter
sooner or later because no one's gonna
care for you when they actually do have
that's why people you know stay and go
yep yeah that's true all I care about is
just being happy it's like happy people
makes happy environment and creative
work mm-hmm yeah well you work for
Disney I think you're happy cuz you get
I am so happy but I mean the department
I'm in right now Disney's an awesome
place to work at I don't think everyone
can say that but some company I can be
but I work in the animation studio and
I'm in a department a specific
department that does attraction and
project shows and like hotels it's just
like everything that's related to the
animation shows and our department is
pretty small and I been there only for
about a month and I have would you like
everybody loving it like the people are
amazing the amount of work that I could
do and the changes I can do and like the
leadership that I have that I could
control and work on it's just so fun
yeah sofa and the people I can meet
because um our team is small but then we
talked to a lot of vendors and different
studios it's so fun yeah I find it so
fast it's a dream job I think a lot of
people don't get hired to Disney
immediately you know you got to work
your way out there right yeah I mean
think about this animation industry is
that it's a fact but you have to know
someone to get into the industry and
forth unfortunately I didn't have that
when I first got in so you have to make
your own I have to yeah I had to find my
way to get in there and I'm like I have
no idea because I was never in that
industry I was in the entertainment
industry either so I didn't know anyone
and that was the only option to get in
it's like you have to know someone I'm
like well there must be another way
because people like me I want to have a
chance to so I created my own chance
opportunity to talk to someone and
fortunately they really liked me and so
I got in that's cool yeah
because it was hard for her because I
know like um she was working on really
cool projects at her last job but
because it wasn't like in the route that
she wanted to go it doesn't matter if
the project is cool to everybody else
you have to enjoy what you're doing
remember her it was making her I was a
miserable but it's more like you know it
is depressing it's the present because
she was working a really well-paying job
before and so for to go from that to go
to something else it's like okay well
this is a good paint job and this is a
good paint job but now I just worked at
another job that doesn't make me happy
so why the [ __ ] did I do a career switch
in the first place so for her going from
here to here it was like okay well
technically I'm in animation which is
where I wanted to be these projects
aren't making me happy yeah so why did I
even switch these jobs in the first
place so you kind of sit there and you
stew we did this in this like what the
[ __ ] am i doing
this is before I was in animation
industry I was in the international
business because with the degree that I
had in the language that I knew I left
abroad working for different
international companies and I I think
the one thing a fact is that I love
meeting people and learning their
language in their culture because once I
get a click from that person be like hey
you know how to communicate with us it's
like very satisfying it's satisfying
yeah
but the downfall was that my job had
nothing to do with creative and so
that's why I decided that I'd come back
to change my career and it was boring
stuff it was boring how many papers do
you want to print today bring in this
year it's like I don't care about the
money I want to be in the creative world
of working with creative people and so
when once I got in I was like this is it
but you know it also depends what kind
of creative work you do yeah like yeah
that's true
it has to resonate with you yeah cuz not
all creative will work out exactly yeah
yeah like we could we could choose if we
wanted to do to go into a different
field like acting right but it's not the
same from what we're doing we get to
create what we want to do and when we've
had these conversations people are like
well you should go into acting well who
the [ __ ] are you to tell me what I enjoy
yeah like just cuz sounds like my
grandma like yeah you should do you
should do a skit about this
like oh well you know you have so much
of a fog you could go into acting cool I
never said I wanted to be an actor so
what the [ __ ] is this conversation oh it
also comes from the ignorance of like if
they think you're a performer you always
want to be in front of the camera and
and it's like well if you're stand up
calm comedian you can do a movie like
you know Jamie Foxx did or whatever you
know it just comes from ignorance
ya know say well right now oh so so
prior to this so Mariel so she's been on
this podcast before and we did another
previous podcast and so she wanted a
Redemption one because she asked me she
she goes well how did I do it what can I
do better I kind of gave her you know I
said a few things I'm very like
straightforward with my stuff yeah but
she was like I gotta do another one I
don't feel what she want to make you
proud I was like one of the podcasts you
guys either have seen or haven't seen
depending on the order that we're
putting this out but I was talking a lot
in it yes we I would say something but
then she wouldn't elaborate on these
stories and so I was trying to fill in
the blanks I had to fill in these blanks
a lot so it sounds like I'm talking over
oh my yeah so seems like you're cutting
her off exactly but if you do that then
the beginning of this podcast well you
thought my dad cut her off yeah yeah you
caught me I was telling about you know
you're asking about like so why aren't
rested in Japanese why what made you
start and I was gonna tell my story I
got too excited he did I was like I'll
let it go I don't have anyone first of
all first of all I didn't cut you off at
all right he totally was gassy I'm
saying there's this beautiful voice
coming in of this TV and you're like
this girl it's not cutting up or adding
to a story though I never got to finish
that story but it's okay don't mean you
don't want me to out you out of this
podcaster I yeah especially with that
fight we had yesterday
Oh oh my god do we have another
you want to talk about you want to talk
about some bad stuff do you there's a
reason why my eyes are super puffy today
yeah you've been crying all night crying
all night crying all day huh it's okay
it's normal
yeah especially when you hurt people's
feelings and you're going into them
do you ever talk about how you make me
cry yeah how do you say how do you say
I'm really sad in Japanese sabi she
Oh Bobby cheering all right deeds cannot
she it's more sense obviously I guess
yeah love me oh yeah baby [ __ ] yeah
Mitsubishi Kazakh you tomorrow all right
guys so that's that concludes this
episode of the genius brain podcast
everybody remember you can find us on
every audio platform and you know on
those Thursdays we got Joe Jitsu cowboy
up in this so just to just to clarify
what's going on a lot of you guys are
like Oh Joe's back on it's because
Thursday's are me and Joe this is our
podcasts on Thursday so that's why if
you see it it's David and Joe is not
David featuring Joe it's our thing so uh
Joe and I'm gonna be on this every
Thursday check that out and on Sundays
we have some new foot and Joe might be
on Sundays and ones to who knows but
those are like the wild-card ones yep
it's gonna be David making girls cry
yeah just be making everybody cry for
some reason you make me cry yet gonna
make you cry
and then she made me cry yesterday too
when she's being mean to me oh so uh
ticket taken and so check us out on
iTunes podcast if you see us on iTunes
give us that five star work here when
they find you
Marielle underscore underscore song
there's two underscores Oh someone took
the other one oh my god son of a [ __ ]
and then yeah check us out
genius brain podcast we'll see you guys
next time stay cool leaving the comments
below about topics she wants to talk
about in people you want us to bring on
babe Aniyah bye bye